معنا بالمخيم بلاطه شرقيه نابلس مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا المدير ومعها نرصد معك
جيفارا اهم رصدته اثناء تشييع جثامين
الشهداء الفلسطينيين وكذلك ردود الفعل حتى
الان عقب ما اوصف بالمجزره في هذا المخيم
مخيم بلاطه
التي جابت كل شوارع مدينه نابلس وصولا الى
هنا الى مدخل مخيم بلاطه ونقل الشهداء
الثلاثه الى منازلهم لالقاء العائلات
النظره الاخيره على ابنائهم الثلاثه لان
هنا الاهالي يؤكدون ان الشهداء ليسوا مجرد
ارقام لكل شهيدا هناك قصه بطبع ايضا في
ذات الوقت كان العشرات من المقاومين
الفلسطينيين يتقدمون
الجنازه اطلقوا الرصاص في الهواء وبالطبع
في اشاره رمزيه هذا ما اكده لنا بعض
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وايضا عدد من
المراقبين عندما يوضع السلاح على جسد
الشهيد سلاحه الخاص هذا معناه ان
الرفاقه سيقومون بمواصله الدرب اي مواصله
عمليات المق